any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
everybody this is such an incredible
treat
a thrill that's why i got into doing
these pandemic podcasts in the first
place to be honest so that i could have
conversations with my buddies and
friends and mentors and teachers
and today it's none other than professor
max tegmark of mit who i've known for
25 years or something like that uh and
uh
and he's really been a huge influence on
me i've i've
stayed in his house i can't believe it i
knew him when he had
little babies and now they're all grown
up and uh and he's known me since
uh long before i had babies let's put it
that way max how are you doing today
i'm doing great and it's so awesome to
see you in these
crazy times and it's not just our
kids that are growing up but that
universe behind you on the sofa
our knowledge of it has grown up too i
remember when we first wrote a paper
together on
taking pictures of our baby pictures of
our universe
oh boy have the pictures gotten sharper
and clearer since then huh
yeah and largely thanks to the work that
uh that you have put in in this
cosmic universe that we inhabit and i
just find it so amazing to keep up with
the things that you're doing
i associate kind of the output of
someone like you
with with a very young you know starting
out wanting to get a job wanting to get
a new career
and yet you're making so much new
content and productivity
and doing so many new creative ideas i
first want to start with though
something provocative perhaps and that
is your neighbor
to check first though and say that of
course
as usual you're being way too kind uh
talking about my contributions to making
those universe pictures better when you
were the one who's actually building
experiments
taking the photos we'll get into that
yeah we'll get into the
the experiment versus theory kind of
debate but first i want to take you
down the hallway as i understand it at
mit uh you guys bump into each other
frequently
this is noam chomsky your buddy i don't
know if you can recognize him but there
he is so
i'm working by the way on a max tegmark
finger puppet so unemployed philosophers
guild who makes these finger puppets
please make one for max because
he deserves it uh but i want to start
off with your latest peregrination
into the field of artificial
intelligence you cross wrote a runaway
smash hit best-selling book
life 3.0 that was one of president
obama's favorite books one of bill
gates's favorite books
one of my favorite books uh you know
we're in the we're in the same league
the three those three names
uh but i want to ask you when noam was
on my show this summer
in uh i should say in 2020 he said
something very provocative
in the context of of neuralink elon musk
who's a friend of yours i know
uh he said it's not gonna work because
they're not asking the right questions
he said
the question of whether or not machines
can think
is too meaningless to contemplate and i
said
that's pretty provocative and he said no
that's not me saying it it's alan turing
in his famous imitation paper imitation
game paper
alan turing said the question is too
meaningless to ask
how do you differ with gnome are you
guys going to go on the faculty club and
have a bare knuckle brawl like we used
to have
i already had a really fun debate with
him in my office
about the future of ai a while back and
i have to say
i hugely respect noam and i think we'll
come back to some of his amazing work on
studying media bias also later in our
conversation but i think on
on the forecast of artificial
intelligence um
i do differ with him i think it there's
very little doubt in my mind that we're
going to succeed
and all the original goals basically
making machines that can one day do
everything we can
unless we wipe ourselves out first by
some other means and i think it's
in as a physicist simply because i
believe that
you and i are quirk blobs i hope you
don't get offended by this
i've been called worse i i think the
reason
you are so smart has nothing to do with
the fact that
the particular quirks you have are
arranged into carbon atoms
and i think people who say that are
carbon chauvinists
and a little bit too limited i think
intelligence is all about information
processing
and it doesn't matter whether the
information is processed by
carbon atoms in neurons and brains or by
some other kind of atoms in machines we
build ultimately
there's no law of physics saying that
we are the smartest kind of cork blobs
that can possibly exist
so the bigger question is is to me is
not
whether it's possible to blow away human
intelligence with machines but just
whether we will be smart enough to
figure out how to do it and hey
we just had the europe's conference
which is sort of like the
the ai rock concert of the year which
keeps
growing exponentially in size and it's
just
quite mind-boggling how fast this field
is progressing
i'm not you know just a few years ago
robots couldn't walk properly
now today we have a viral video of
robots dancing in the new year at boss
dynamics
not long ago you know we didn't have
self-driving cars now we have
self-landing rockets thanks to elon and
not long ago
we didn't have machines that could even
beat us at the asian board game of go
and now just the other week google deep
mind came out with the latest the mu
zero which not only crushes us at go
and chess and japanese chess shogi
but also in all the atari games from the
old times pretty much
without even being told the rules so
things are happening fast
and i think it's a juggernaut that
is pretty much unstoppable unless some
other disaster strikes
because there's just so much money to be
made in this so many smart people are
going into it
and uh the question isn't to me whether
we're gonna ultimately have uh
superhuman ai but just whether it's
gonna be the best thing ever to happen
to humanity
or the worst so when i look at uh when i
think
of the future as you are consumed with
and for good reason we we have kids but
even if we didn't have kids or we'd be
concerned about the future
and i want to think back in a thought
experiment to
this finger puppet guy now this is
galileo who i consider
you know the grandest hero of all time
and at least in science
but of course he was in a deeply flawed
individual he had
biases he wanted to confirm the
copernican hypothesis at all costs
i'm rereading the dialogue i never read
it in full but it's one of the most
masterful books ever written
in popular science and paved the way for
for you to pave the way for me
uh to become a writer of popular science
works but galileo i was thinking
you know he he would say things uh you
know kind of about the human intellect
such as you know anyone who thinks he
understands one thing
is a fool if he thinks that means he
understands everything
and i wonder you know the more that we
think we understand ai
is that lulling us either into a
cassandra
you know fear that the sky is is going
to fall and and
we're all going to be doomed unless you
listen to to uh to people that are
warning about us
or conversely are we being too passive
and neglecting the implications
that could be uh terminal uh for the
human species
i think it's the latter and i i love the
call for humility you're making here i
mean being humble
is i think at the very heart of what
science is all about
you know galileo and others
succeeded exactly because they
acknowledged that we did not understand
things that everybody else thought they
already understood like how objects move
right aristotle had
said this dumb thing you know over a
thousand years earlier that things move
up with constant speed until they
realize they should be going down with
constant speed and
it was exactly admitting that we didn't
understand that made people look more
closely and get the real
truth with ai of course the fact of the
matter is
we have very we understand too little
about how it works
most accidents that happen today with ai
happen because people have a shiny black
box that
contains some neural network or whatever
they train then
and they put it in charge of something
that actually affects
human lives without understanding it
well enough
we've seen even very simple examples of
like boeing wished they had understood
the 737 max automated system better
before they deployed it right and knight
capital
wished they understood their ai trading
system better before they lost
10 million dollars a minute with it on
wall street for 44 minutes straight
until someone was like
turn this thing off so i actually this
is what we work on in my mit
ai research group intelligible
intelligence it's exactly this humble
attitude that hey we don't understand
these systems well enough
let's see if we can open up the black
box and make ai systems that
are as good but that we can understand
better so we have some reason to
to trust them and i also think you
alluded to the future of humanity right
we clearly don't understand well enough
what impact
this is going to have on society people
i think today are mostly worried about
the wrong things because we've seen
silly hollywood movies like the
terminator and
are worried about robots coming to kill
us
what we should primarily be worried
about now is
uh robots coming to hack us
i mean why is our world so polarized
today
into filter bubbles because
ai you know because companies who just
had a pretty legitimate goal to
make money they deployed on a massive
scale
algorithms to make you spend as much
time as possible looking at ads
and they had not understood what this
was going to do to society they had not
understood and i even
even have a lot of friends at facebook
who had were in charge of some of this
and didn't understand it
that what would happen was these
algorithms would discover
really good ways of hacking our minds
you know
showing us things that really triggered
us
and uh if they were true they were that
was a bit limiting
it would be more easy to trigger people
if you showed people things that were
not true
and uh in general showed people things
that confirmed or
sort of brought out the worst in us and
here we are now and it
suddenly really challenged democracy
because of ai hacking us and that's just
i think a good wake-up call for us to
realize that there are probably many
other unintended consequences that can
happen
as well so your humility is good let's
start by thinking we don't understand
the systems that well and we don't
understand
what they're going to do to us so let's
try to win this race i think between
the growing power of this tech you know
and the understanding and wisdom we have
about it
so that we can steer it in a good
direction my friend john talin
who many who listen to this uh
me know is the founder creator one of
the creators of skype
he has this lovely metaphor about
rockets if you can
do good things with rocketry it's not
enough to just make the engines really
powerful
you also have to figure out how to steer
the rocket
and you also have to think through where
you want it to go that shouldn't be an
afterthought after launch right and i
feel we're kind of making that mistake a
little bit now
with ai yeah i i i couldn't agree more
you know i always say
you know intelligence is knowing that
you can skydive
you know and and knowing that you can
actually skydive
twice without a parachute you just can't
do it alive the second time
so uh but i wanted to stick one more
time for one more second to galileo
because in his hand he's holding a
telescope which you and i know he did
not
invent somebody else invented the
telescope uh
hans lip in the netherlands is rumored
to have invented it but he did something
with it that no one had ever done before
and that he looked like this
with it at night and he saw these these
objects that were called planets and
moving
in different ways but i wonder you know
if he had been born a hundred years
earlier
would he still have had this impact on
on humanity on
as the father of experimental let's say
father of observational astronomy i
don't think anyone can argue with that
with a telescope
uh i wonder are are there people now
that are born
you know were you born too early to take
use uh to make use of what ai could do
for good
and conversely are there wars let's say
let's say ai could be used to actually
avert disaster through
better processing news etc uh imagine in
1916
if uh before archduke ferdinand was
assassinated and that led to this
catastrophe which ultimately killed 100
million people plus
around the world imagine if there was
some like news aggregate like say
actually it's not that important here's
what you should pay attention to
talk to us about what you're trying to
unleash now
in a force for good to give a tool to
someone who might be able to wage
peace not war using ai to augment what
humans can do
that's a wonderful question there i
think
it's important to remember that
artificial intelligence is not
evil and it's also not morally good it's
just a tool
like all technology is you know fire
it's the same way you can fire is good
for warming your house up in the winter
especially here in
the boston area it's but you can also
use it to burn down your neighbor's
house
so that's that's exactly what where i
was going with that rocket metaphor
right the key thing is what you use it
for and i think
what you mentioned there is that it's so
important not just
how well-meaning people are and how
talented they are and how
motivated they are but also what
information they have access to makes a
huge
huge difference and right now
if you look at um how ai is used
in terms of information flow i would say
that it's mainly used by very powerful
entities to manipulate people into
watching
more ads and sometimes it's also used by
governments and other powerful entities
to make people vote a certain way or
think a certain way
it's more used sort of by empowering the
big guys
against the little guys but that's not
something inherent
in technology right if you take a very
powerful
technology like that's very expensive
like a nuclear weapon
it will always be more something that
big powers have a monopoly on because
they're expensive and
unfortunately also hard to get but ai is
not like that
it's incredibly cheap you know everyone
has computers and phones and it's just
once you have the code you can share it
so there is really no fundamental reason
a priority that it has to be
mainly helping to dominate
the little guy as opposed to empowering
the little guy and this gets me really
on fire
i think one of the most promising paths
to a good future is to use
these same technologies and to empower
people to make our democracy
work better to enable that you know the
little guy
to see through ruses and manipulation
and and so on and
you know right now take fact checking
for instance which has become all the
rage right
it's who is it's mainly the big guys
like facebook
they're fact checking the little guys
and saying brian
your tweet is violating community
guidelines or it's wrong or whatever
but what if you brian could fact
check cnn or fox news
you know with ai that's you have
basically no power as an individual
today if you see something that's
wrong or misleading to have any major
feedback on on them
um but look at another example and i'll
give you some hope here look at amazon
right
if you buy if you buy something from
amazon
and it just doesn't work and it explodes
when you start using it
you're going to give it a one-star
rating and a lot of other people are too
and
now suddenly that empowered the little
guy and
the vendor that made this is going to
really hurt and put a lot of effort into
making
the product better but i and i
i would like to see the news let me
landscape become more like that as well
where
where people who try to manipulate us
too much
actually pay a pretty strong
reputational price
so basically rewind now to march
right lock down mit
kick me out of my office i need to do
something to stay sane here so this was
my big covert project
i recruited an awesome team of mit
students and i've been working very hard
all year and especially on nights and
weekends
to use machine learning to study news
bias
part of it is a research project and we
can talk more about some of the
pretty hilarious findings we've we have
like
for example how you can see with machine
learning that many newspapers put
deliberately ugly photos of
of politicians they don't like
and it's done about equally actually on
the left
and the right side of the spectrum but
even more importantly we
so we started building tools that people
can use so we made this news aggregator
you can go to it now and improve the
news.org
it's work in progress so we love
feedback but the idea basically is to
help you break out of your filter bubble
by making it really easy to see
alternative perspectives on the same
thing you know
right now if if someone for example is
a democrat and voted against trump but
they would like to see a little bit
understand a bit better the other side
it's very hard for them
because chances are if they go look at
breitbart news they're just going to get
offended very quickly
and that'll be the end of that
experiment and vice versa if you take a
republican and they
start reading cnn but
what if there was an easy way to find
actually more nuanced articles
that you disagreed with like if you're
sitting next to someone on an airplane
who you realize is from the other side
of the political spectrum and that
person is just really respectful
and and and willing to answer your
questions that's interesting right
uh many people tend to blame filter
bubbles on on you
and say oh it's just people are so dumb
they just want to hear what they agree
with
but my colleague here at mit professor
david rand actually feels that this
has done research showing that it's not
so simple
people are interested in hearing things
you disagree with as long as it's
respectful
no if you're writing a paper and someone
comes and says you know
brian it's really interesting stuff
you're doing but i think there's a sign
error in equation five which invalidates
everything
surely you're going to be interested to
know that right are you going to be
pissed at the person who said that
or or if you have a company and someone
points out to you that there's some
fundamental
the flaw of safety flaw in your product
you don't want to know that right and
and um
so on approve the news it becomes super
easy to see
respectful articles on the other side we
have these sliders you can just go
slide it from left to right and see what
others are saying and if you want more
nuanced we have a new one slider
if you want to get offended you can pull
it to the expensive side
ad hominem attacks on your side
and there's also it's not just the usual
left right but another equally
interesting axis i think is the one that
has to do with corruption
you know because generally the powers
that be tend to get kind of corrupted in
various ways
and that means people there's not so
much
tendency to criticize the most powerful
so we have a slider for that if you go
to the anti-establishment
side you'll find a lot of smaller
newspapers
that are happy to criticize both parties
and criticize big companies and even
push back a bit on nationalism you know
most countries will mostly have
newspapers saying good things about this
their country
and why all conflicts are the other
country's fault so if you live in
america
of course china is the bad guy russia is
the bad guy
if you live in china of course it's
going to be the other way around
as scientists you know we we like to see
all sides of the story
so this also makes it very easy to do
that
that's my covert project that's great
[Music]
but i think it's so innovative and it's
exactly in keeping with your ironically
named
moniker mad max because you're like uh
we're gonna call this episode the way of
the happy cosmologist
and i'd be remiss we have about 15
minutes to go right now but i'd be
remiss if i didn't ask you
uh at least one question about my
favorite subject
which is cosmology which is how we met
uh and that has before we go
cosmic though can i just add one more
thing about this sure to me
of course it's your show yeah you know
some of my friends i think are too
pessimistic and say we're screwed it's
impossible to have a media landscape
where you can
easily find the truth you know but hey
we know an example of a field where
there's been tons of controversy
where we actually have a really good
media landscape
science yes look at physics you
mentioned galileo right
so suppose he had put out his paper or
rather given a speech or whatever and
said hey you know i think
earth is going around the sun and now
the 1600s facebook says fact-checked by
the pope
no hope fact-checker says it's the sun
going around the earth
fortunately the science media system
works a lot better than that right
in fact you've probably never had an
issue trying to figure out whether some
theorem is true or false
because different people were
politicizing the proof
or whether you know whether some
soul some other other star system
discovered was really there or not
we have a really good system and i think
it's
it's in so this is my basic vision how
can we take
the things that really work in the
scientific
search for truth that have made our way
of finding the truth and writing
about an immediate system so effective
and take the best parts there
and apply it to new to the mass media
without it being as boring to read as
scientific papers and i think i think
we actually and when i say we i mean of
course
a lot of scientists are dead now who
helped build this up
have developed some really good tools
yeah that the rest of society can
benefit from
wouldn't it be amazing if if people had
an easier time finding out
correct facts about controversial
political issues as as you have
you know if you want to know the mass of
the electron
yeah i think the the issue i think if i
were to beta test it or whatever before
it was sprung out i would see like
what can we do for the public to
increase trust in scientists because as
you're saying
we have an obligation because the the
community
the world trust us so much and last
finger puppet for now but carl sagan
said you know
we live in a dangerous age because we
have this incredible technology
and we have you know i always say we we
have uh
sorry let me let me pause we'll we'll
edit this part out but carl sagan said
we live in an age where
never have we had so much technology
with so little comprehension
of what the technology is based upon i
had barry barrish
on the podcast a couple of months ago
and he said
basically we stifle curiosity but then
we
we
basically get turn over this weapon of
mass destruction potentially in the form
of social media
to people that have no idea even how a
television works
but uh so this brings up my point my
kind of hobby horse when it comes to
this is
i guess i'm less interested you know you
know science the word science means
knowledge it doesn't mean wisdom and i'm
kind of curious do you think we could
have
artificial wisdom not just artificial
intelligence i think
i think we already do but can we have
artificial wisdom in other words
the the experience the know-how the
the benefits of hindsight to apply it in
a way that it is most efficacious
and also most beneficial always striving
towards that theological
metric you is so brilliantly connected
back now with this wisdom race
that i was talking about earlier right
the sagan quote is exactly about what
happens when you lose the
wisdom race when your technology power
grows faster than the wisdom with which
we manage it
and i think trying to improve
the media system and how we get
information is really core
actually for help for the wisdom
development because for example what is
one aspect of wisdom is how should we
live our lives ourselves personally what
decisions should we make you know to
flourish
and how should another one is how should
we organize our society and
and make decisions so that we all
flourish
you know collectively this is an
experimental science just like
the physics you do right there are many
different places where people have tried
different things
different people have tried different
life strategies different countries
different regions different cities have
if you can have a really good system of
communicating about this and
seeing what works what doesn't work
then the wisdom can be caught the things
that do work will be copied
and will all be just so much better off
for it
get your reaction to i've had a lot of
conversations with folks like peter
diamandis who's an mit
uh train graduate and he of course is
very interested in these
things that he says grow exponentially
and
in his book which just came out with
stephen cutler who's going to be on the
show as well
uh who's got a new book out about things
that are impossible which is appropriate
for the into the impossible podcast
they both talk about these abundant bold
all these things are
exponentials and i make the point every
year so today is new year's eve
2020 and you'll be listening to this out
there in
january or so of 2021 but every year i
make the same
new year's resolution i want to drop
five pounds and i did it this year max i
dropped five pounds
um from my double chin to my stomach so
it it didn't go very far
but it i i dropped it okay but no
seriously so i always say well
what if i lost those five pounds over
the course by just doing one percent
per day but it was exponential so it
compounds so the first ad lose one
percent
of the weight of the five pounds and
they keep going it turns out as you know
that you don't lose 365 percent or you
don't have
you know exponential gains don't work
that way you actually at the end of the
year if you improve or lose weight at a
rate of one percent per day compounded
as einstein called it
i lied when i said that was the last
puppet here's a puppet one more puppet
for you max
um that uh it's the greatest invention
of the human mind is compound interest
so but they sneak up on you the hockey
stick is real
but it occurs very late you'll actually
only lose
about like uh maybe four ounces between
now
and 72 days from now which is the
doubling period at one percent per day
roughly
so in other words if i lose uh five
pounds in a year the first 72 days i'll
only lose
four ounces which i could undo by
drinking this delicious
jocko go um not not a sponsor of the
podcast
i wish but anyway what is it about the
human mind's inability to perceive and
detect these exponentially growing
things
like ai
well i think by and large we're very bad
at
detecting these exponential things which
is of course why we
have things sneak up on us you know if
you were looking at an antelope running
across the horizon it would not
exponentially speed up and
so we did these linear interpolations so
we knew where to run and catch it and
eat it and stuff like that i think
more broadly i think um challenge that
we have unfortunately a lot of
challenges where our mind evolved to
really work well in the environment we
lived in
tens of thousands of years ago and now
we live in a completely different world
so i think the only hope is that we can
actually use the methods of science
which don't have these inhibitions to um
aid our mind and none let's get things
right
even when you send rockets to mars you
know you're not really just trusting in
your gut
intuition you actually trust the science
that's right that's right and as you
know we point out if you were off by
just half a degree
you know when you're going to the moon
that's enough to get you off course and
so it benefits you
as a pilot i know you want to get on
course as soon as possible
because these things get exponentially
amplified
uh away uh i so many more things i want
to talk to you about
max maybe we'll come back and do a part
two because i have to ask you the
questions
uh that i ask all my guests uh on the
into the impossible podcast and then we
have another
appointment for another podcast so in
the remaining five minutes
i would love to take you into the
impossible and ask you the following
three questions the first is that your
homeland
uh namesake or not namesake but your oh
the patron saint of sweden uh alfred
nobel
uh he i i stole this from barry barrish
when he came to visit
uh when he uh when he is one of the
chocolates
right no no comment and i will not say
if this is my hanukkah gelt left over
but alfred nobel he had no children he
was not married and yet he cared deeply
about the future of humanity
and one of the things he did is he said
my prizes shall go to people only if
they have conferred
the greatest benefit to mankind he left
money but he also
left that as his ethical will i want to
ask you max tegmark
what sort of wisdom would you want to
leave not monetary i know i'm going to
get most of that
in 150 years when you finally spring
from this mortal coil
but max what would you want to leave
your biological but your ideological
children of which i count myself as one
as a form of inheritance from the wisdom
of max tag mark not the intelligence
i think the most important thing i've
learned so far as a scientist
is that we humans are just the masters
of underestimation
and we need to think bigger you know not
only have we underestimated the size
of the resources and we have we
realized that everything we thought
existed what was just a tiny part of
something grander right the planet the
solar system the galaxy
is super cluster of galaxies the
universe you know maybe more
but even more inspiringly we realized
that we totally underestimated our
ability with our human intelligence to
understand the world through science
and therefore to improve the world with
technology
so i think that's my big message
never underestimate how much you can
influence things
and when you start to realize how much
influence we have or
the very natural next step is to think
okay then how can i make sure this
influence becomes good
and then go out and do things there's no
better way to
fail than to persuade
yourself that you have no influence and
there's no point in even trying
that's beautiful max well i've got two
more questions but we're out of time for
now
so i will invite you back onto the into
the impossible podcast if nothing else
then to
you know just justify a really good time
for me and my audience but max
it's such a treat to go into the
impossible with you the many more things
we're gonna talk about uh i just
i just can't say how much uh i've
appreciated and grown from knowing you
your graciousness uh i can't i can't
think of someone else who's really done
so much with nothing in return i mean
when you started mentoring me as a
graduate student
there's nothing i could i can't do
anything for you now maybe i could
babysit your kid or
you know if they come to ucsd i'll take
care of them but whatever but
but bottom line is you've done so much
with nothing in return i want to thank
you so much for going into the
impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you